so you take a photo in a cardinals
de'andre hopkins jersey but i can't do
that i'm just telling you
but that's your friend do that yeah but
you trying to make it about a bet and
like you trying to have me go viral and
look crazy no this should be a good bet
because i'm just whoever's got the
better record next year
you should feel good about you're going
to hire that bro
bro look at the squad look at the coach
man shot me hey what the [ __ ] is he this
dude talking about stop playing
so so so it's a bad you're gonna make
let's bet some money
yeah
i'm not batting money you're richer
scared money don't make no money we
could do 500
500 1000 bro a thousand
see i'm not i'll do 400 i'll do 400 400
i'll do [ __ ]
400 next year regular season record
who's got the better record overall why
you want to let's do game for game
that's that's going to take too long to
get 400 dollars
game for game shuffle game so first time
we play you we we beat y'all
no no we're playing twice
i said the first time we beat y'all fine
or do you want it who gonna win the most
out of them two games
but then it's like what if it's if y'all
it's a todd and it's a tie okay let's do
that all right all right babe we can do
that we do that i don't know what you
think let me think
um
cause we probably see y'all in the
playoffs
but see i don't know about the playoffs
we're talking regular season only two
divisional games
see that's not that's not a
like
like you betting on it to be a tie but
like that's going to be like it it's
going to be like
you feel me that's not a good bet it's
cool like we can break even like for
sure easily find the first game
let's just beg this game for game bro
okay fine each game four hundred each
game
of the game so i might be down eight
hundred
yeah you might be down hey honey it
should be a terrible look and stop
mentioning that 49er [ __ ] it's over with
like hey how annoyed were you that i
posted that on instagram i wasn't even
tripping this whole text to be like your
petty is [ __ ] yeah i'm just like well
you petty like
bro you trying to smut my name made me
look bad that's crazy you know what's
funny is i came away from that game
saying man that sucked but at least i
got a nice piece of content
you ain't [ __ ]